Back in UE5, use the Quickly Add to the Project button on the main toolbar, and import the Datasmith file named Context.udatasmith that's been provided to you.
You are asked for a location on disk, create a folder named Theatron.
When asked for import options, make sure all options are enabled and import the file.
You may get a warning or two. In this case, the warning is about a Twinmotion material using the Grunge feature, which is not compatible with UE5.
Aside from that, everything seems to be properly in place.
Note the presence of multiple Twinmotion cameras that were derived from the Media panel in Twinmotion.
Keep in mind that Datasmith doesn't cater for collision data, and LODs behave erratically at times.
We'll look how to deal with that later in this class.
Let's bring in another part of the project.
Repeat the import process, this time for the vegetation part.
When you get to the Import Options dialog, disable cameras as you don't want them duplicated.
Once the Datasmith file is imported, look at the Outliner.
You have the Context and Vegetation folders representing the two Datasmith file hierarchies.
Both contain a Background entry.
That's a duplicated actor representing the circular city background around the scene.
You can safely delete one of those.
The other thing you'll notice as you zoom in with the imported trees, is that although they import properly, there is a problem with the display.
This promises to be fixed soon, but for now, the easiest fix is to save your level and all its assets, and restart the project.
The trees look better now, although that last LOD level leaves a lot to be desired.
And as mentioned, Datasmith doesn't carry over any collision information between apps.
Dealing with LODs and collisions one tree type at a time would be too time consuming.
So let's look at an alternative way of importing the data.
To delete all vegetation in the scene and in the project, start by selecting the Vegetation top parent in the Outliner.
Press Ctrl-Shift-D to select the hierarchy underneath and then press Delete.
Confirm all deletion and then select the files and folders in the Vegetation folder in the Content Browser and do the same.
Now that all vegetation is removed from the project, we'll import it again using a different technique.
In the empty Vegetation folder in the Content Browser, right-click and create a Dataprep asset. Name it Vegetation.
Double-click the asset to edit it in the Dataprep Editor.
Here, you can decide how to sort and adjust your incoming data in a node-based editor.
Start by selecting the file to import, in this case the Vegetation Datasmith file.
Click the Import button to see the file contents.
Note that the Datasmith file contains duplicates of elements you already have in the scene, such as the background and the cameras.
To get rid of those, you can filter the selection using an actor label.
You can type the name of an actor you wish to select, such as Background, and then add a Delete Objects node to that action.
Add another actor label to the graph, this time looking for cameras.
To select the child actors, add a Select Hierarchy node to the action.
And finally, a Delete Objects node to finish off that process.
To test your work, click the Execute button on the toolbar.
After a moment, you'll notice that the background and the camera actors have disappeared from the outliner.
Next, consider that all the trees in the incoming file have the label Growth in them.
Add a new actor label node based on the name Growth, and then add a Set LOD node to the action.
Disable Auto-Screen Size if you plan to define how the LODs will transition.
Add three LOD array elements, or three LOD levels if you will.
That should be enough for our purposes.
Adjust the numbers, you can follow my lead or experiment with other numbers.
This will take care of adding LODs for all trees.
Similarly, add a Set Convex Collision to the action.
Leave the default values as they are.
This will apply collision detection for all trees in the scene.
Execute the recipe to test the results.
This will take a while, but it's still faster than doing the work manually.
Once you're happy, click the Commit button to send the results to the editor.
Once you're back in the editor, save your data using the Save All button.
You still need to restart your project to refresh the texturing, but otherwise, you should be good to go.
As good as visual data prep is, sometimes it may just be overkill.
For the hero building, a simple import will work just fine.
Import the theory.datasmith file as you have learned earlier.
Again, make sure the Cameras option is disabled to prevent duplicates.
You'd still need to delete the duplicated background that is also part of this datasmith file.
For the most part, everything seems to be working well, but there are adjustments to be made at the lighting level.
All incoming lights are currently set to Static, as evidenced by the red warning in the viewport.
It suggests that light baking is needed for the scene.
If you're planning to use Lumen instead, all incoming lights should be set to Movable.
Other light issues can be viewed at night. Set the time of day to about 9pm.
Some spotlights could use a burst of energy, but the bigger problem lies in the street lights and bollards.
The lights associated with those should have shadow casting turned off to see any effects.
To fix all these issues, you need a tool to bulk edit lights.
You can use the Light Mixer tool in the Window menu.
The tool lists all the lights in your scene. It can also list properties that you need to edit.
You can add or remove properties by right-clicking the menu bar.
You already have the Mobility property displayed.
Add Cast Shadows, Intensity, and Indirect Lighting intensity to the mix.
Select any of the entries in the Light Mixer and then press Ctrl-A to select all the lights.
You can now easily change their mobility status to Immovable.
The Light Baking Red warning doesn't disappear from the viewport, which needs a refresh. We'll do that in a moment.
Scroll down the list and select Street Lights in the Light Mixer.
Right-click and choose Select Immediate Children.
Do it again on the sub-selection to ensure the whole hierarchy is selected.
Disable Cast Shadows to ensure they're off on street lamps and bollards.
Unfortunately, the effect is not immediate in the viewport.
Save your level and reload it to see the effect.
Note also that the Light Baking message has disappeared.
The Street Lights intensities could use a little boost.
In the Light Mixer, select all Streamlined entries and set the light intensities to 800 all around.
Again, it is unfortunate that you must save and reload the level to see the effects.
Here's hoping that this becomes more interactive in a future release.
Go back to a time of day around 1pm when you're done.
Next, we'll discuss LODs and collisions.